today the supreme court heard one of the
biggest reproductive rights cases in
years the justices deliberated over a
mississippi abortion ban after 15 weeks
of pregnancy their ruling on
mississippi's law could have
far-reaching ramifications beyond the
state after about two hours of hearing
arguments justices indicated all six
conservative justices indicated that
they would go with allowing states to
roll back abortion access so we want to
bring in jennifer poppeck to talk about
today's hearing and what it means in the
ongoing abortion battle battle jennifer
is the legislative director for national
right to life committee jennifer welcome
to quick take
what is your reaction to this news after
we're now hearing that the conservative
members of the court are uh potentially
going to vote in favor of rolling back
abortion access
sure i would say from the point of view
nationwide to life we're very encouraged
by what we heard today
now it's difficult always to know for
sure just based on oral arguments alone
you know what sort of outcome we're
going to get but we're encouraged i
think based on the questions
you know there's a majority of justices
who seem likely to in some way either um
you know explicitly overrule the roe
versus way decision as modified by casey
or to you know do something a little a
little uh narrower at least allowing um
reach like you know more pro-life laws
at an earlier stage than viability so
either outcome i think we're encouraged
so tell me a little bit about the
viability question here does does your
organization uh feel that the viability
should be
changed should be addressed by the
supreme court and if so how likely do
you think that is given that you know it
would be really unprecedented for the
court to overturn something like roe v
wade they've never done something like
that before
no that's that's correct i mean it's
been you know 30 years since the last
sort of landmark case which was the
casey decision
and there's just been you know a real
pattern here although we have this undue
burden standard that was sort of
governing and saying you can't put an
undue burden way of a woman prior to
viability
it's you know it's it's left a situation
where it's very difficult to pass laws
to protect unborn children so we're
certainly in favor of moving that back
and giving states you know state
legislatures passing laws working
through their own process to say hey
this is a point at which we want to
protect the baby maybe it's the baby can
feel pain maybe it's the baby you know
has a heartbeat and brain waves
there are other places at which the
state might come in and say we have a
right in the life of this unborn child
you know and and be able to pass more
meaningful restrictions sure but but at
15 weeks even if a fetus was given a lot
of life-saving efforts from doctors and
experts uh it would be really hard for
that fetus to survive so so how do you
kind of defend that argument
sure you know the mississippi law itself
does have a lot of exceptions for help
of the mother um life mother that sort
of thing we think this is a this is a
very developed baby yes it is
not able to fully survive on its own
even you know the earliest preemie
babies are surviving at 21 22 weeks
so
you know this is a very late stage of
pregnancy this is a very developed baby
this is one that has met a lot of you
know physical milestones and a baby
that's likely to survive and um you know
if the pregnancy continues so this this
is a stage you know at which
i think a broad swath of the american
people would say
you know there might be some different
opinions on abortions early in pregnancy
this is a very late stage of pregnancy
i want to talk about the state angle
here because i know that your
organization and the conservative
justices are leaning uh now that we know
how they're reacting to these arguments
they're leaning towards allowing states
to decide on this issue
what do you envision that looking like
for the country moving forward it would
seem that the south would pretty much
enact bans on abortion and the north
then more liberal states wouldn't do
that what do you think that that does to
the makeup of the country in the
electorate
you know sure and we don't know what the
supreme court is going to do you know if
it's if it's a full reversal of roe is
modified by casey i mean this would be a
battle then that was fought at a state
by state level but it's possible the
court does something a little short of
that um but also would be good from our
point of view yeah we absolutely see
that there's you know certain states
like new york and california have you
know very permissive abortion laws in
their states not just limited to the
south like ohio and other places like
that um that would you know do more to
protect unborn children and i think what
we would look for in a lot of states is
really common sense
you know sort of um look at a point
where a woman has an opportunity to know
she's pregnant you know we we
you know you have a set of
exceptions for um you know like physical
health problems that a mother might have
or clearly the life of the mother you
know i think states will do a patchwork
of things and you know that will that
will mean some states you know a woman
will
be in a position to if she's going to
seek abortion she'll need to do it
sooner than if she lived in new york um
so it it if the court goes as far as
overturning row it will return the
states to sort of a patchwork approach
and let's talk about mississippi in
particular which is the subject of
today's hearing there's only one
remaining clinic in mississippi and the
state already had a 20-week limit prior
to this additional 15-week law that's in
question that that already put a lot of
limits on the number of people who were
able to seek abortions in the state um
does it feel to your organization that
that wasn't enough
well the i think you know what happened
is a lot of states were very
enthusiastic when they saw the makeup of
the you know the new makeup of the
supreme court and a lot of states were
you know
hopefully to get laws in in front of the
court i know that the one clinic in
mississippi was doing abortions up to 16
weeks
um and i think the state of mississippi
was trying to assert an interest like
look the abortions at this stage are
actually very dangerous to the woman and
look uh babies at the stage feel pain so
you know
whether or not what the what might be
going on at the time we wanted to be
able to protect these babies in law you
know i mean more clinics couldn't
feasibly open in in the state so it's a
it's it was a point about drawing
attention to the humanity the unborn
child showing these markers where the
state wanted to protect
final question to you jennifer i know
that a fascinating and unprecedented
argument being made in this mississippi
case in front of the supreme court is
that the undue burden thing is is no
longer a valid argument because women
and men are equal women have more access
to capital now according to these
attorneys so they are able to
be moms and care for a child it's not an
undue burden anymore how do you square
that though with the fact that the
majority of women who do seek abortion
services in this country are low income
and don't actually have equal access to
capital
well what i say is i think we we need to
do more work as as pro-lifers to connect
women with pregnancy resources centers
with the resources that they are you
know are able to get through that state
medicaid programs through wic through
you know there's so there's so many
sorts of different resources out there i
think the ability to to
uh put a baby up for adoption is a far
simpler process now than it was when
rose decided and there was a focus today
on the fact that there's so many state
protective laws about if a woman has a
baby she can drop it off no questions
asked there is no sort of ongoing
requirement for the you know for to to
be an active mother of the child um what
we're talking about is protecting sort
of the unborn unborn life
jennifer poppeck legislative director
for national right to life committee
thanks for joining us we're going to
continue to cover this story as we get
updates from the supreme court for now
i'm madison mills in new york